Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody, welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. If you have read the title of today's episode, you will know exactly what we're talking about. And what we are talking about is the tricky trap of self-improvement, when it goes too far, whether there is such a thing as too much self-help content. And whether it is beneficial to constantly be chasing something better for
大家好，欢迎回到《你的二十岁心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s）。在这个播客中，我们探讨二十岁时面临的一些重大生活改变和转折，以及这些变化对我们心理的意义。大家好，欢迎回到节目。欢迎再次收听本播客。无论是新听友、老听友，无论你在世界的哪个角落，很高兴你能回来收听新的一期节目，和我们一起剖析二十岁的心理。如果你读过今天节目的标题，就会知道我们今天要聊什么。我们要聊的是自我提升这个棘手的陷阱——当它走向极端时会发生什么，到底有没有“过多的自我求助内容”这回事，以及不断追求更好的自己或改善生活是否真的有益。
ourselves or improving our lives. Let me firstly begin by addressing this. The irony is not lost on me that you are tuning into what is in essence a self-help podcast and yet we are talking about the downfalls of self-help, right? You know, I have literally written a self-help book. It is titled Person in Progress. Like there is probably not a more self-helpie title for a book out there. than that. And a lot of what I speak about on this podcast is really geared towards knowing yourself better, knowing your brain better, knowing your psychology, elevating ourselves. And yet in the background, personally, I have become a little bit disenfranchised with this kind of approach to our lives, with this feeling that there is constantly something that we need to improve, we need to fix, we need
首先，我想指出这一点：我很清楚其中的讽刺意味——你正在收听本质上属于自我提升类的播客，而我们却在探讨自我提升的消极面，对吧？你知道的，我甚至写过一本自我提升类书籍，书名叫《进行中的人》（Person in Progress）。大概没有比这更具有“自我提升”风格的书名了吧。我在这个播客中谈论的许多内容，其实都是为了更好地了解自己、了解大脑、了解心理，从而提升自我。然而在幕后，就我个人而言，我对这种生活态度、对那种“我们必须不断改进、修复、解决问题”的感觉，已经感到有些幻灭和厌倦了。
to work on. Personally, you know, I think I have taken self-improvement way too far in the past. And I have fallen into a trap of thinking that if I just wake up at 5 a.m. If I just quit caffeine, if I just do as many meditation retreats as possible, if I read that book, if I only listen to motivational podcasts, my life will be better. And I will finally uncover the secret to happiness. Guess what? None of those things have ever made me happier. And none of those things have ever made me more successful because none of those
就我个人而言，我觉得自己在过去把自我提升推得太极端了。我曾陷入这样一种思维陷阱：只要我早上5点起床，只要我戒掉咖啡因，只要我尽可能参加最多的冥想静修，只要我读了那本书，只要我只听励志播客，我的生活就会变得更好，我也终将解开幸福的秘密。你猜怎么着？这些事情从来没有让我更快乐过，也没有让我更成功过，因为打从一开始，这些活动根本就不是什么问题所在。
activities were actually a problem to begin with. All of those efforts were really just a distraction for something deeper. And yeah, it has made me a little bit disillusioned with this space and in a more broader sense, this industry that has been built around this space. I read this quote the other day that really summarizes it for me. You can't self-help your way out of a life that isn't aligned with you to begin with. And I for one have really been discovering how that is, true. And so today I want to bring my thoughts to you guys to consider. I want to talk about the nuances of self-improvement from the perspective of someone who is loosely and by accident kind of based their career in this space. And as someone who can also openly really point to the downsides and point
所有的这些努力，其实都只是为了掩盖更深层问题的分心之举。是的，这让我对这个领域、以及从更广泛的意义上来说围绕这个领域建立的产业，产生了一些幻灭。前几天我读到一句话，很好地总结了这一点：你无法通过自我提升，来摆脱一个本身与你不契合的生活。而我个人确实一直在体会这句话的真实之处。所以今天，我想把我的想法带给大家思考。我想从一个半路出家、阴差阳错把职业生涯建立在这个领域的人的视角，来探讨自我提升的细微之处；同时，作为一个能够坦诚指出其弊端的人，我也想指出，外界确实存在着大量令人窒息、没有帮助且不太实用的信息。
to the fact that there is a lot of information out there that is suffocating and unhelpful and not very useful. This is obviously not going to be a strictly anti-self-improvement episode per se, far from it. I think I would be shooting myself in the foot and I would literally be burning my career to the ground if I just sat here and hated on self-improvement because I do think that there are parts of it that are incredibly important and healthy. What I really want it to be is a bit of an investigation into when it can go too far and who benefits from us not being happy with what we have. I also want us to kind of redefine self-improvement and recognize that it's not just about external actions. It's definitely not just about consumption. It's not about perfection.
这显然不是一期绝对反自我提升的节目，远非如此。如果我坐在这里痛恨自我提升，那我就是在搬起石头砸自己的脚，简直是亲手毁了自己的职业生涯。因为我认为自我提升中确实有非常重要且健康的部分。我真正希望探讨的是，它何时会走向极端，以及当我们对现状不满意时，究竟是谁从中获益。我还希望我们能重新定义自我提升，认识到它不仅关乎外在行动，绝不仅仅关乎消费，也不是追求完美。
Self-improvement should really be based on self-discovery and living a good, balanced life. And beyond that, a really happy and fun life. And I think that that is something that has kind of been lost in the flurry of self-improvement, information and books and speeches that, we have been exposed to recently. So I am very excited for this episode. I'm very excited to kind of give you guys a peek behind the curtain as someone who operates in this space and operates in this industry and kind of reveal what authentic self-improvement content looks like when it's just trying to sell you something and so much more. I just hope that today's episode kind of challenges your assumptions and gets you to really think about what real personal growth means to you. And also
自我提升真正应该建立在自我发现以及过上美好、平衡的生活的基础之上。除此之外，还要过上真正快乐、有趣的生活。我认为，在最近我们接触到的铺天盖地的自我提升信息、书籍和演讲中，这一点似乎已经有点迷失了。所以我非常期待这一期节目。作为这个领域和行业的一员，我很高兴能带大家一窥幕后，揭示什么是真正的自我提升内容，什么时候它只是在试图向你推销产品，以及更多内容。我只希望今天的节目能挑战你们的固有假设，让你们真正思考什么是对自己真正有意义的个人成长。同时，
maybe think about whether the amount of self-improvement content you are consuming has become harmful. You know, that's a question that you guys have to answer for yourselves. But I hope I give you the tools to at least think about it. Without further ado, hopefully you can sense my excitement and maybe my fear in doing this episode. But let's get into it. This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when they're There is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
也许还能思考一下，你所消费的自我提升内容的数量是否已经变得有害。你知道，这是你们必须自己回答的问题。但我希望我能为你提供一些工具，至少去思考这个问题。废话不多说，希望你们能感受到我在做这期节目时的兴奋，或许还有一丝恐惧。让我们开始吧。这是一档iHeart播客。真人保证。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。
I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the I-HartRadio app,
在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端蜕变成一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。可在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at a podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
欢迎收听《回望1979》（Look Back at a Podcast）。1979年对我来说是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说也很重大。我是萨姆·杰伊（Sam Jay）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的嘉宾包括朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜爱的作家。
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe
比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代。84年真是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为没有比这更重要的一年了。收听《回望1979》，可在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。嗨，大家好！欢迎收听《艰难学习》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行那些在别处其实并不安全的坦诚对话，
to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor it signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones.
但在这里，你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着盔甲，向世界发出信号：你可别想惹我。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做。收听《艰难学习》，可在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。2023年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）被指控生下了一对双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋。迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。
As the season continues, Laura Owens. finally faces consequences. Listen to a love trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. To begin, let's really dig into a fundamental question here. What is so powerful about self-help content? What is so powerful about self-improvement content that compels us to buy, listen, engage in it as often as we do?
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。收听《深陷爱河》播客，可在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。首先，让我们深入探讨一个根本问题。为什么自我求助内容具有如此强大的力量？为什么自我提升内容具有如此强大的魔力，促使我们如此频繁地购买、倾听并参与其中？
to understand this, to understand this innate drive many of us have towards self-improvement, we have to dig deep into an area called humanistic psychology, which essentially focuses on human potential and the mechanisms behind personal growth. Specifically, we have to understand this concept of our actualizing tendency. So our actualizing tendency was first identified by an American psychologist called Carl Rogers, and he basically revealed, discovered, believed that humans, every single one of us have an innate drive to fulfill our unique potential. We each have a drive to grow, to become fully functioning, to be successful in one form or another. Within every single one of us, there is a seed that wants to
为了理解这一点，为了理解我们许多人对自我提升的这种内在驱动力，我们必须深入研究一个被称为人本主义心理学（humanistic psychology）的领域，它主要关注人类的潜能以及个人成长背后的机制。具体来说，我们必须理解“自我实现倾向”（actualizing tendency）这一概念。自我实现倾向最早是由美国心理学家卡尔·罗杰斯（Carl Rogers）提出的，他基本上揭示、发现并相信人类——我们每一个人——都有一种发挥独特潜能的内在驱动力。我们每个人都有成长、变得功能健全、以某种形式取得成功的驱动力。在我们每个人的内心深处，都有一颗想要
become a tree. This process is so natural, inherent, instinctual to us since the time we are born. You know, our body wants to grow bigger and stronger. Our limbs want to elongate. Our bones want to gain mass. And the same for our minds and our emotional realm as well. We want to learn more. We want to strive. We want to thrive.
长成参天大树的种子。这个过程对我们来说是如此自然、内在和本能，从我们出生起就是如此。你知道的，我们的身体想要长得更高更壮；我们的四肢想要伸长；我们的骨骼想要增加密度。我们的心灵和情感领域也是如此。我们想要学习更多。我们想要奋斗。我们想要蓬勃发展。
We want to be successful. We want to find our purpose. Now, this looks different, obviously, across different cultures, people, personalities. Some people strive for gold medals. Some people strive to push themselves physically. Other people strive to be a better member in their community or to be inventive, creative, to understand themselves more. But basically at the end of the day, what this theory really says is that we need something to work towards, otherwise we feel
我们想要成功。我们想要找到自己的人生目标。现在，显然这在不同的文化、人群和个性中表现各异。有些人争取金牌；有些人努力在体能上突破自己；另一些人则努力成为社区中更好的成员，或者富有创新精神、创造力，更多地了解自己。但归根结底，这个理论真正告诉我们的是，我们需要有为之奋斗的目标，否则我们就会感到
incomplete. So this idea is actually beautifully complemented by another theory that you probably know of called Maslow's hierarchy of needs. It's that famous pyramid that I'm sure you've seen many times, but the theory behind it is that human motivation isn't random. It actually follows a pattern that extends from a very baseline level of simple needs to a high level need to self-actualize. So to really just break down this pyramid that I'm sure you've seen many, many times, at the very bottom of this pyramid that we need to achieve before we achieve anything else is our physiological needs. Food, water, sleep, shelter. These are things that allow us to survive. Once those needs are reasonably met, we then want to achieve safety needs.
不完整。所以，这个想法实际上与另一个你可能知道的理论相得益彰，那就是马斯洛的需求层次理论（Maslow's hierarchy of needs）。就是那个著名的金字塔，我确信你已经见过很多次了，但其背后的理论是，人类的动机并非随机的。它其实遵循一种模式，从最基层的简单需求一直延伸到自我实现的高级需求。为了真正拆解这个你一定见过很多次的金字塔，在金字塔的最底部——在我们实现其他任何目标之前必须满足的需求——是我们的生理需求。食物、水、睡眠、住所。这些是让我们得以生存的东西。一旦这些需求得到合理的满足，我们就会转而追求安全感。
feeling secure, having stability, personal security. Once we have that comes loving and belonging. We want connection. We want friends. We want family. We want a sense of community. And then we can seek our esteem needs. So self-respect, achievement, recognition from others. Those things can only be pursued if we have all of those things that have come before. That is not the top of the pyramid, though. The top of the pyramid, the thing at the very top, the pinnacle of this pyramid, is self-actualized. This is the ultimate human desire. What Maslow says, every single one of us is working towards. It is the drive to become everything that we are essentially capable of becoming.
感到安全，拥有稳定性，个人安全。在我们拥有这些之后，便是爱与归属感。我们需要联系。我们需要朋友。我们需要家人。我们需要一种社区归属感。然后，我们可以寻求尊重需求。即自尊、成就、来自他人的认可。只有当我们拥有了前面所有的东西时，这些需求才能被追求。不过，这并不是金字塔的顶端。金字塔的顶端，位于最顶端的东西、这座金字塔的巅峰，是自我实现。这是人类终极的渴望。正如马斯洛所说，我们每一个人都在为之努力。它是成为我们本质上有能力成为的一切的驱动力。
It really centers on our drive to find something that we're good at, to find purpose, to live a life that feels really meaningful. And so our ardent, often obsessive pursuit of self-improvement can actually be seen as a direct manifestation of this inherent human need to climb Maslow's ladder to aim for that profound internal sense of fulfillment and personal concurrence. So from the humanistic perspective, we're really drawn to growth and self-improvement because it satisfies this inner longing for meaning. If we are improving, it means that our life has purpose. It means that there is something bigger than us that we can achieve and feel satisfied with.
它真正核心在于我们寻找擅长的事物、寻找人生目标、过上真正有意义的生活的驱动力。因此，我们对自我提升的热切、甚至常常是强迫性的追求，实际上可以被视为人类攀登马斯洛阶梯、追求深刻内在满足感和个人和谐的这种固有需求的直接体现。所以，从人本主义的角度来看，我们之所以会被成长和自我提升吸引，是因为它满足了我们对意义的内在渴望。如果我们正在进步，就意味着我们的生活有目标。这意味着有某种比我们更宏大的事物是我们可以实现并从中感到满足的。
There's also the secondary element of this, which is that simply accomplishing something, working hard, being rewarded for that, naturally just feels really, really nice. That, you know, delayed gratification and sense of pride. Like, it's a really good feeling to say, I wanted this thing, I went after it, and I got it. When we learn a new skill, when we run a marathon, when we overcome a challenge, like there is an inherent reward to that that really fuels, growth and fuels further efforts to improve. And it's this drive to engage in things from the inherent satisfaction that they bring that researchers call intrinsic motivation. Now, this is the
这里还有一个次要因素，那就是仅仅是完成某项工作、努力工作并因此得到回报，自然而然就会让人感觉非常非常好。那种延迟满足感和自豪感。真的有一种很好的感觉，可以说：我想要这个，我去争取了，我得到了。当我们学习了一项新技能、跑完了一场马拉松、克服了一个挑战时，其中有一种内在的回报，它真正推动了成长，并推动了进一步改善的努力。正是这种由于活动本身带来的内在满足感而参与其中的驱动力，研究人员称之为内在动机（intrinsic motivation）。现在，这是
third concept you really have to understand if you want to understand why you love self-improvement. Intrinsic motivation is basically the purest form of motivation because it doesn't rely on others, it doesn't rely on external things. It is the joy and the satisfaction that we derive purely from what we get out of something and from enjoying the process. When this is our reason for pursuing self-improvement goals, when we benefit mainly because of how something makes us feel competent, makes us feel successful, makes us feel like we have control, self-improvement is primarily a beneficial thing.
如果你想理解为什么自己热爱自我提升，你必须真正理解的第三个概念。内在动机基本上是最纯粹的动机，因为它不依赖于他人，不依赖于外在事物。它是我们纯粹从某件事中获得的收获以及享受过程中所感悟到的快乐和满足。当这是我们追求自我提升目标的理由时——当我们主要因为某事让我们感到能干、感到成功、感到我们能够掌控一切而受益时，自我提升主要是一件有益的事情。
This is the space in which self-improvement is really beneficial and in which I think all of us can benefit from having something that we want to achieve, and having something that we do feel compelled to work hard for for our own satisfaction. And so what happens when this natural striving for improvement becomes unhealthy? How does it become unhealthy as maybe a better question? It becomes unhealthy mainly because of external factors. This inherent drive for growth is a very pure positive thing, but when it becomes competitive, when it becomes a way that we want,
这就是自我提升真正有益的领域，我也认为我们所有人都可以通过拥有想要实现的目标、拥有为了自身的满足感而不得不努力工作的目标而从中受益。那么，当这种对进步的自然追求变得不健康时，会发生什么呢？或者换个更好的问题，它究竟是如何变得不健康的？它变得不健康，主要是由于外在因素。这种对成长的内在驱动力是一种非常纯粹积极的事情，但当它变得具有竞争性，当它成为一种我们想要
want to prove our self-worth to others, it turns very nasty and toxic. So people who really criticize self-improvement and the self-improvement industry, their main argument is that this approach to life is too simplistic and would have us derive our entire worth entirely from what we can achieve, from our ability to push ourselves, from our ability just to meet our goals, rather than the fact that we have worth purely for existing. Basically, what they're saying is that self-improvement has become twisted and toxic because in this current day and age, it isn't about what you can do for yourself and it isn't about how you can improve how you feel about yourself. It's basically how you can improve how other people see you. Often the push for self-improvement
向他人证明自己自我价值的方式时，它就变得非常恶劣和有毒。因此，那些真正批评自我提升和自我提升产业的人，他们的主要观点是，这种生活态度过于简单化，它试图让我们完全从自己能取得的成就、从我们推动自己的能力、从我们实现目标的能力中获取全部价值，而不是基于我们仅仅因为存在就具有价值的事实。基本上，他们所说的是，自我提升已经变得扭曲和有毒，因为在当今这个时代，它不再关乎你能为自己做什么，也不关乎你如何改善自己对自己的感觉。它基本上变成了你如何改善别人对你的看法。通常，对自我提升的推动
stems from societal conditioning rather than a purely innate drive. In today's, you know, very hyper-connected achievement-focused world, there is an unspoken pressure to constantly be optimizing because of how that will make you appear to others, because it will allow you to get ahead, because it will allow you to kind of beat the competition. Just before we talked about how the purest form of motivation is intrinsic motivation. On the flip side to intrinsic motivation, we have extrinsic motivation. And this is really what we're talking about here. Extrinsic motivation, when that takes over, it means that we only do an activity for an external reward or to basically avoid punishment. So we lose weight to impress or attract someone. We run a
源于社会的塑造，而不是纯粹的内在驱动。在当今这个非常高度互联、以成就为中心的社会中，有一种无声的压力，逼迫你不断优化自己，因为这会影响你在他人眼中的形象，因为这能让你领先，因为这能让你在竞争中胜出。就在刚才，我们讨论了最纯粹的动机形式是内在动机。与内在动机相对的是外在动机（extrinsic motivation）。这正是我们在这里要谈论的。当外在动机接管一切时，意味着我们做一项活动只是为了外部奖励，或者基本上是为了逃避惩罚。所以，我们减肥是为了给某人留下深刻印象或吸引某人。我们跑
marathon to post it on social media. We pursue our artistic passion purely because we think it's going to make us famous. We want a promotion simply because we want to prove that people who doubted us were wrong. The difficulty with relying purely on extrinsic motivation is that we actually fall out of love and we forget the reason why we started something to begin with. Basically, we tell our brain, the only reason to improve ourselves is if other people acknowledge that we have improved, if other people acknowledge that this is worthwhile. And so suddenly what was something that we once genuinely enjoyed doing, felt passionate about doing, wanted to do for ourselves, turns into a chore, it turns into a discipline exercise. Sometimes it even turns into an activity that we
马拉松是为了发到社交媒体上。我们追求艺术激情，纯粹是因为我们认为它能让我们成名。我们想要升职，仅仅是因为我们想证明那些怀疑我们的人是错的。完全依赖外在动机的难点在于，我们实际上会失去对初的热爱，并忘记我们当初开始做这件事的原因。基本上，我们是在告诉大脑：提升自己的唯一理由，就是别人承认我们进步了，别人承认这是值得的。于是，突然之间，曾经让我们真心喜欢做、充满激情去做、想要为自己去做的事情，变成了一项杂务，变成了一项纪律训练。有时它甚至变成了一种活动，被我们
use to kind of punish ourselves. It also turns into something that can be profited off of. And this is where the self-improvement industry really steps in as a major factor and a major motivator that intensifies our drive to improve in a negative direction. Think about it. This industry is worth $42 billion. And the only reason it's worth that much is because it excels at identifying insecurities, identifying our desire for betterment and to impress others and for control, and then offering us a seemingly very perfect solution. This industry is constantly putting forward aspirational figures. is that have very curated perfect lives that are then paired with something that you can buy to have that life yourself. And it's very hard to resist that glossy, beautiful, perfect packaging.
用来惩罚自己。它也变成了一件可以牟利的事情。正是在这里，自我提升产业真正介入，成为一个主要因素和一个强大的动力源，将我们对进步的追求朝负面方向激化。想想看。这个行业的价值高达420亿美元。它之所以能达到如此高的价值，唯一的理由是它极其擅长识别我们的不安全感、识别我们对变好、对给别人留下深刻印象以及对掌控感的渴望，然后向我们提供一个看似非常完美的解决方案。这个行业不断推出那些
You know, if you see someone who is in a perfect relationship, who has a perfect body, who has perfect skin, a perfect routine, of course you're going to want that because we have that natural aspirational drive. This industry really does thrive because, it does meet a genuine human need for progress, right? That's not a bad thing. People do want to feel good about themselves. It has become toxic in recent years because it's often completely unrealistic. What it's telling you is possible. It demands complete personal transformation that is actually very hard to achieve and very costly to achieve. The other thing is that there's a powerful kind of feedback loop at play here. Our desire for growth and
生活完美精致、令人向往的人物，并将其与你可以购买以过上那种生活的产品搭配在一起。要抗拒那种光鲜亮丽、完美无瑕的包装是非常困难的。你知道的，如果你看到一个人拥有完美的关系、完美的体型、完美的皮肤、完美的日常，你当然会想要这些，因为我们有着那种天然的向往驱动力。这个行业之所以能够蓬勃发展，是因为它确实满足了人类对进步的真实需求，对吧？这不是一件坏事。人们确实希望对自己感觉良好。它在近年来变得有毒，是因为它往往完全不切实际。它向你灌输的可能性，
improvement creates demand and the industry supplies it and then it intensifies our dissatisfaction with ourselves and our insecurities to drive even more demand so that we want their supply. So this is why we often feel like the bar keeps moving. This is why we often feel like we are chasing an ideal that's just not reachable. It's because the moment that we perhaps achieve the dream life that is being sold to us, well, they can't make money off of you anymore. You know, you're no longer a customer. And so the bar does have to keep getting higher so that there is still demand for what they're putting out. What I mean by this is that it's not just feeling, like nowadays, having a good life isn't just
要求进行彻底的个人转变，而这实际上极难实现且代价高昂。另一件事是，这里存在着一种强大的反馈循环机制。我们对成长和进步的渴望创造了需求，而这个行业则提供了供给，然后它又加剧了我们对自己的不满和不安全感，从而激发出更多的需求，让我们想要他们的供给。这就是为什么我们常常觉得标准不断在提高。这就是为什么我们常常觉得我们在追逐一个根本无法触及的理想。这是因为，一旦我们实现了向我们兜售的梦想生活，好吧，他们就再也无法从你身上赚钱了。
feeling full and feeling happy and having a job that brings your purpose. It's also having a skincare routine. And once you have the skincare routine, it's also having a really good night time routine that involves taking a certain supplement or that involves a certain eye mask. And once you achieve that, they go, okay, well, actually, that's not going to make you happy. The next thing is that you have to have the perfect body. And then once you have that, then we actually need to give you this. There is no end goal here. There is always going to be a deficit in your life that a product or a thing that you can
你知道的，你不再是一个客户了。因此，标准不得不不断提高，这样他们推出的产品才依然有市场需求。我的意思是，这不仅仅是一种感觉——如今，拥有美好生活不仅是
buy will seemingly fulfill and make better for you. The thing that a lot of people in this industry have actually gotten really good at, and I think this has become the tricky thing, is that they mix the perfect lifestyle with occasionally actually talking about failure and with occasionally showing themselves as imperfect. So you feel like they're more like you. And by doing that, they also really stoke the sense that, hey, maybe I can actually be like this person. Have you noticed this? I've noticed this a lot recently is. there are a lot of, you know, self-improvement individuals who will only talk about failure in the context of it making them better. They will only talk about their imperfections in the context of it helping them love themselves more.
感觉充实、感觉快乐、拥有一份能给你带来人生目标的工作。它还得有一套护肤流程。一旦你有了护肤流程，还得有一套非常棒的夜间流程，其中包括服用某种补充剂，或者使用某种眼罩。而一旦你做到了这些，他们就会说：“好吧，其实那并不能让你快乐。接下来，你必须拥有完美的体型。”一旦你拥有了那个，我们实际上需要给你这个。这里没有终点。你的生活中总会存在某种缺失，而你可以购买的产品或事物似乎能够填补并改善这种缺失。这个行业中的许多人其实已经变得非常精明，我认为这已经变得很棘手，那就是他们将完美的生活方式，与偶尔真正谈论失败、偶尔展示自己的不完美结合起来。所以你会觉得他们更像你。通过这样做，他们也极大地煽动了这样一种感觉：嘿，也许我真的能成为这样的人。你注意到了吗？我最近注意到了很多，
They will only talk about hard things in the context that they have learned or they have overcome that hard thing. There is never this discussion of like, oh, sometimes this is just hard. and this doesn't have a solution and you have to just sit in the suckiness of life. There is always a but, there is always an and, there is always some philosophy or some book or something that you can then do that they have done that will fix your problem. The thing is, though, you can't buy your way into a more fulfilling life. you can't buy your way into happiness. One of you guys, one of the listeners actually messaged me about this and I thought what you shared was perfect.
有许多所谓的自我提升博主，他们只在能让自己变得更好的语境下谈论失败。他们只在帮助自己更爱自己的语境下谈论自己的不完美。他们只在自己已经吸取教训或克服了困难的语境下谈论艰难的事情。他们绝不会这样讨论：“噢，有时事情就是这么艰难。”而这并没有解决办法，你只能去忍受生活糟糕的那一面。总有一个“但是”，总有一个“而且”，总有一些你可以做的哲学、某本书或某种他们做过的事情来解决你的问题。然而问题是，你无法通过买买买来换取一个更有充实感的生活。你无法通过买买买来换取幸福。你们中的一个人，其中一位听众实际上就此给我发了私信，我觉得你分享的内容简直太完美了。
So I'm going to share it here. They gave the most beautiful summary. If you could buy your way to self-improvement and to perfection, rich people would have no problems. And yet they do. And in turn, some of the happiest people have the least because this process that we are all aiming for isn't about what we can buy, isn't about a product. isn't about what we can achieve for others. It's about personal introspection. And there is no market price for that.
所以我将在这里分享它。他们给出了极其美妙的总结：如果你能通过买买买来实现自我提升和完美，那么有钱人就不会有任何烦恼了。然而他们却有。反过来，一些最快乐的人拥有的却最少，因为我们都在追求的这个过程，不关乎我们能买什么，不关乎一件产品，不关乎我们能为别人取得什么成就。它关乎个人的内省。而这没有市场价格。
There is no thing that can fast forward that process. You actually just have to do the hard work. There's an important question that really emerges from this as well, which is, is self-improvement actually making us more self-centered? Because it's subtly becoming more about improving social standing and appearances and the external impression we have rather than how we feel, when no one else is around. And I think the answer is yes.
没有任何东西可以快进这个过程。你其实只能去做那些辛苦的工作。由此也衍生出一个重要的问题，那就是：自我提升是否真的让我们变得更以自我为中心？因为当四周空无一人时，它正在潜移默化地演变成更多地关乎提升社会地位、外表以及我们在外人面前的外在印象，而不是关乎我们的真实感受。我认为答案是肯定的。
I do think that self-improvement has made us think about ourselves way too much. Self-help is mainly a Western idea that makes most of its money in Western countries, like the US, like the UK, like Australia, like Canada, where we know psychologically that a lot of societies are more individualistic rather than collective. The thing is, though, human happiness and joy, fundamentally has community at its center. We were built to not care about ourselves
我的确认为自我提升让我们过多地关注自己了。自我帮助主要是一个西方概念，它在西方国家（如美国、英国、澳大利亚、加拿大）赚取了大部分资金。从心理学角度我们知道，许多西方社会更加崇尚个人主义，而非集体主义。然而问题在于，人类的幸福和快乐，从根本上讲是以社区为中心的。我们生来就不是为了只关乎自己，
as much as we care about others in the collective. And we were built as well to be loved, to belong, to be cared for, to care for others. And when we are entirely focused on self-improvement, we obviously have less space to think about how we could be a better neighbor. We have less space to think about how we could give back. We have less space to think about
比起关心集体中的其他人，我们对自己的关注其实没那么重要。我们生来也是为了被爱、为了归属、为了被关心、为了关心他人。当我们完全专注于自我提升时，我们显然就没有足够的空间去思考如何成为一个更好的邻居。我们没有空间去思考如何回馈社会。我们没有空间去思考
whether we are available to our friends our families, to think about whether we are a good sibling, we are a good partner, we are a good daughter, whatever it is. One of the most robust studies on human happiness ever done, ever conducted was a longitudinal study from Harvard. And they looked at people across their lifespan and they found that more than personal achievements, more than appearance, the biggest predictor of whether you were happy was meaningful relationships. Yet when, you know, self-improvement becomes hyper-individualized, it can erode that for a lot of people. It can mean that we aren't focusing on what really matters.
我们是否有时间陪伴我们的朋友、我们的家人，去思考我们是否是一个好兄弟姐妹、好伴侣、好女儿，无论是什么。有史以来关于人类幸福的最严谨、最长期的研究之一，是哈佛大学的一项纵向研究。他们研究了人们的一生，发现比起个人成就，比起外表，决定你是否幸福的最大预测指标是意义深远的良好关系。然而，当自我提升变得极度个人化时，它可能会侵蚀许多人的这一点。这可能意味着我们没有聚焦于真正重要的事情。
Now, of course, there's a difference between being self-focused, being self-obsessed and being selfish. And you guys know, even I'm an advocate for being selfish sometimes and just saying, I've got to lock in and focus on myself because I want more for me, I need to do this for me, I need this sense of fulfillment. But how long can that truly last before you look around? and realized, you know, in the pursuit of becoming the best version of me, I'm actually no longer a nice person to be around.
当然，关注自我、自我迷恋和自私之间是有区别的。大家也知道，甚至连我自己有时也主张自私一点，直接说：“我必须集中精力关注自己，因为我为自己想要更多，我需要为了自己这样做，我需要这种成就感。”但是，在你环顾四周之前，这种状态究竟能持续多久？
I'm no longer someone who's fun. I'm no longer someone who actually is joyful and enjoys any part of this. Where does that lead us? Well, I want to introduce you to the concept of self-improvement burnout and why it has become way more common than you may think after this short break. So stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs,
然后意识到：“在追求成为最好版本的我的过程中，我其实已经不再是一个好相处的人了。”我不再是一个有趣的人。我不再是一个真正快乐、能从这其中任何部分获得乐趣的人。这把我们带向了何方？好吧，在短暂的休息之后，我想向大家介绍“自我提升倦怠”（self-improvement burnout）的概念，以及为什么它比你想象的要普遍得多。所以请继续收听。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康与健身专家等展开对话，
when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical
越过那些不切实际且过于复杂的、主导健康产业的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引发炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上惊慌失措的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端蜕变成一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。可在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。
and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。法则一：千万不要惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。法则二：也千万别惹她的朋友们。我们总是说，相信你的女友。我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在《女友们》的这个新季中……天哪，这就是同一个男人。
There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And Rule 2, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist.
一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的诈骗犯约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一下。我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在乎。所以她们决定自己动手。我心想：哦，见鬼，绝不。我发誓我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。收听《女友们》。
I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends.
相信我，宝贝。可在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上拍打小姬姆（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小姬姆到底有什么关系？
Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim?
好吧，你可以在《回望1979》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近的一集，马克·拉蒙特·希尔大谈80年代的快克可卡因。需要澄清的是，84年对我很重要，不只是因为快克。我随时准备聊聊快克，不过为了让大家知道我的意思。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack.
所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的线索。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在了台面上。谢谢你补充完那句话。我认为没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。收听《回望1979》，可在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。
So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
欢迎来到我的新播客《艰难学习》，我是主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是：特里·方丹（Trip Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，在我们追求某样东西的过程中，我们太过于沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are
拥有了那个东西。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在人间做个好人很重要吗？你做个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两码事。
in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different.
兄弟，这是两个不同的层面。绝对是的。那是两种不同水平的信任。我希望你纯粹只是去做一个好人。加入我基尔·盖恩斯的行列，我们在我的新播客《艰难学习》中，就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的iHeartRadio应用程序，搜索“Learn the Hard Way”，立即收听。有一件事我认为正变得越来越普遍，那就是我们正在精疲力竭——不是因为我们必须做的事情，而是因为我们觉得为了成功和引人注目而“需要”做的事情。从某种意义上说，有时自我关怀已经演变成了一种奇怪的精神自残形式。
mentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free, Our Heart Radio app, search learn the hard way, and listen now. Something that I think is becoming more and more common is that we are becoming burnt out, not by things we have to do, but by things that we feel we need. to do in order to be successful and impressive. In that way, sometimes self-care has kind of turned into a weird form of mental self-harm. I have this thing that I do when I'm feeling overwhelmed where I look at my to-do list because I realize that a lot of stress obviously comes from my
我有一个习惯，当我觉得自己不堪重负时，我会去看我的待办事项清单，因为我意识到很多压力显然来自于我的待办事项清单，但它通常来自于那些根本不配呆在上面的事情。我会查看我的待办事项清单，把它分成“我必须做的事”、“我想做的事”以及“完全是多余的、几乎毫无意义或可有可无的事”。每当我感到压力时，我都可以向你保证，那个“额外事项”列表、“可选”列表和“想要”列表里，已经塞满了我觉得为了给别人留下深刻印象而“必须”做的事，或者我觉得为了成为最好的自己而“必须”做的事，而实际上它们正在剥夺我许多的快乐。诸如：好吧，今天我需要洗一个“全套澡”（everything shower）。今天我至少需要走20,000步。今天我需要完成两次锻炼。
to do list, but it typically comes from things that actually don't deserve to be on there. And I will look at my to do list and I'll break it down into things that I have to do, things that I would like to do and things that are like complete extras almost entirely pointless or optional. And anytime I am stressed, I can guarantee you that that extras list, that optional's list, that would like to list has become full of things that I feel like I have to do to impress others or that I feel like I have to do to be my very best self when actually they're kind of rubbing me of a lot of joy. Things like, okay, today I need to take and everything shower. Today I need to do at least 20,000 steps. Today I need to do my two workouts.
今天我需要备餐。是的，这些事情听起来确实不错。是的，我确信这些事情能让我成为一个更好的人。但实际上在那一刻，它们并没有。它们只是在制造更多的压力。在那些时刻，根本没有发生任何自我提升。这全都是自我虐待和自我破坏。这就是我所说的“自我提升倦怠”。这是一种特殊的精疲力竭，当你不断地逼迫自己、不断地争取更多、不休息、不反思时就会发生，因为你太沉迷于完美生活的概念和那些实际上并不能真正帮你在当下取得成功的外部目标。你的身体和心灵，就像一台机器，你没有……
Today I need to meal prep. And yes, those things would be nice. And yes, I'm sure those things would better me as a person. But actually in that moment, they're not. They're just creating more stress. And there's no self-improvement actually happening in those moments. It's all like self-flagulation and self-sabotage. This is what I call self-improvement burnout. It's a specific kind of exhaustion that happens when you're constantly pushing yourself, you're constantly striving for more, you're not taking breaks, you're not reflecting because you are too caught up in this idea of a perfect life and these outside goals that aren't actually really helping you be successful in that moment. Your body and your mind, you are on a machine, you're not
今天我需要准备一周的餐食。是的，那些事情会很好。是的，我确信那些事情会让我成为一个更好的人。但实际上在那个时刻，它们并没有。它们只会产生更多的压力。在那些时刻，实际上并没有发生任何自我提升。这一切都像是自我鞭笞和自我破坏。这就是我所说的自我提升倦怠。这是一种特殊的疲惫感，当你不断地逼迫自己、不断地争取更多、不休息、不反思时就会发生，因为你太执着于完美生活的概念和那些实际上并不能真正帮助你在当时取得成功的外部目标。你的身体和心灵，你就像一台机器，你没有
a machine that is designed for endless optimization without periods of recovery and decompression. In fact, a study that I read recently essentially concluded that every single one of us needs at least three and a half hours of downtime a day to maintain optimal brain health and to actually feel well rested and to feel good in ourselves and our body. Some estimates would even tell you that you need more than that. You need four or five hours. This is how much time our very ancient bodies and minds would have been used to in the past. this is what they were designed to experience compared to today in a modern context where every single hour of our day seems accounted for. You have to work for eight to ten hours. Then you have to do exercise and you have to commute and you have to focus on some outside activity that you're invested in and you have to see your friends and you have to do chores.
一个旨在进行无休止优化而没有恢复和解压时间的机器。事实上，我最近读到的一项研究基本上得出结论，我们每个人每天都需要至少三个半小时的空闲时间，以保持最佳的大脑健康，真正感觉休息好了，并在内心和身体上感觉良好。有些估计甚至会告诉你，你需要更多的时间。你需要四到五个小时。这就是我们非常古老的身体和头脑在过去所习惯的时间。与今天相比，在现代社会中，我们一天的每一个小时似乎都被安排得满满当当，这就是它们生来就经历的。你必须工作八到十个小时。然后你必须锻炼，你必须通勤，你必须专注于你投入其中的某个外部活动，你必须见朋友，你必须做家务。
And all of that does actually accumulate. And it means that we actually don't function as well as we could. Essentially, I'm making the argument that we need more space to simply just exist rather than do. If chasing self-improvement becomes this very rigid, unyielding master, it could completely strip away the joy that you're meant to have about your life in the first place. You know what I need to talk about here? We need to talk about how self-improvement can turn into an obsession with tracking metrics rather than with how we're feeling.
所有这些实际上确实在积累。这意味着我们的运作确实不如我们本可以做到的那样好。基本上，我的论点是，我们需要更多的空间来单纯地“存在”，而不是去“做”。如果追求自我提升变成了这样一个极其僵硬、毫不妥协的主人，它可能会彻底剥夺你原本应该从生活中获得的快乐。你知道我在这里需要谈论什么吗？我们需要谈论自我提升是如何变成一种对追踪指标的痴迷，而不是对我们感受的关注。
You know, there are apps for everything these days. for your steps, for your food, for your sleep, for your productivity. They're helpful for accountability, but they're also a little bit of a trap. If every aspect of your life is quantified, optimized and measured, like you do lose joy. Numbers become the goal. If working out only becomes about hitting a certain number of calories burned, do you even enjoy the movement? If writing only becomes about hitting a word count,
你知道，现在到处都是各种应用程序。为了你的步数、你的食物、你的睡眠、你的生产力。它们对问责制很有帮助，但它们也是一个小小的陷阱。如果生活的方方面面都被量化、优化和衡量，你确实会失去快乐。数字成了目标。如果锻炼仅仅变成关于燃烧一定卡路里数的指标，你还会享受运动本身吗？如果写作仅仅变成关于字数统计，
are you actually making your best work and are you actually connected with creative flow? And this is where toxic self-improvement can often disguise itself as discipline. We might tell ourselves, no pain, no gain, you know, I just need to push through this. Nothing good comes without hard work. Yeah, sometimes that's true. But sometimes discipline is actually just creating unhealthy internal pressure. That means that when you finally get to the goal, you don't even enjoy it because you've sacrificed so much that the process of getting there,
你真的在创作最好的作品吗？你真的与创作心流连接了吗？这就是有毒的自我提升经常伪装成纪律的地方。我们可能会告诉自己，没有付出就没有收获，你知道的，我只需要挺过去就行。没有艰辛就没有美好的事物。是的，有时候确实如此。但有时，纪律实际上只是在制造不健康的内部压力。这意味着当你最终达到目标时，你甚至无法享受它，因为你牺牲了太多，以至于达到目标的过程，
has brought you zero happiness. Discipline is a very important part of life. Discipline is what brings great things into the world and does allow you to meet your goals. But I really like to follow the idea of an 80-20 split. There are going to be periods of your life where you are working really hard towards something. I think about, you know, my final year of high school or my final year of uni or even sometimes when I was writing my book or when I'm working, there are really busy periods. And sometimes you do have to lean into the fact that there is a higher goal that you are really excited about, that you want to work hard for. You also need that 20% to ground you. And you need that 20% to be able to look around and remain attached to
没有给你带来零快乐。自律是生活非常重要的一部分。自律能为世界带来伟大的事物，并确实能让你实现目标。但我真的很喜欢遵循80-20的分配原则。你的人生中总会有这样一段时间：你正在为某件事非常努力地工作。我想到了，你知道的，我高中的最后一年，或者我大学的最后一年，甚至有时在我写书的时候，或者当我工作的时候，确实有一些非常忙碌的时期。有时你确实需要倾向于这样一个事实：有一个你非常兴奋的更高目标，你想为之努力工作。你也需要那20%来让你脚踏实地。你需要那20%来环顾四周并保持对
the life you have right now. It's very easy to get lost in the pursuit of discipline because it's so romanticized, but a lot of people who I see occasionally who are quite disciplined actually don't have very interesting lives and they actually aren't really interested in anything other than their goals. And perhaps that's what they want for their life and I'm not someone to judge them or tell them not to do that. But personally, for me, I don't want to get to the end of my life and look around and realize that I spent my whole life disciplined and trying to improve myself in trying to optimize and I actually am going to end up in the same place as everyone else. Is life really about how much you can optimize your time or how much you can enjoy your time?
你现在的生活的联系。迷失在追求自律中非常容易，因为它被高度浪漫化了，但我偶尔看到的许多非常自律的人，实际上并没有非常有趣的生活，除了他们的目标之外，他们对其他任何事情都不是真的感兴趣。也许这就是他们想要的生活，我不是那种去评判他们或告诉他们不要这样做的人。但就我个人而言，我不想走到生命的尽头时环顾四周，却发现我这一生都在自律，都在试图改善自己，试图进行优化，而我最终的结局其实和所有人一样。生活真的是关于你能把时间优化多少，还是关于你能享受时间多少？
We also have to be cautious at the fact that sometimes discipline is a sneaky way that our brains can rationalize extreme behaviors in the name of a goal. If you are someone who is quite obsessive, if you are someone who finds they really struggle with perfectionism, they have to do things perfectly or they can't do them at all, you should kind of maybe approach discipline with a little bit of caution because it's a slippery slope. It's one I found myself on where what starts with wanting to be productive comes with being unable to quit even when the thing you're pursuing is no longer making you happy, even when your life is kind of falling apart. External goals that you put 120% of yourself into are actually at the end of the day, you know,
我们还得保持警惕，因为有时候自律是我们大脑以追求目标为名合理化极端行为的一种狡猾方式。如果你是一个非常强迫症的人，如果你发现自己真的很挣扎于完美主义，必须把事情做得完美，否则就干脆不做，你可能应该带着一点谨慎来对待自律，因为它是一条滑坡。我发现自己就曾身处其中，最初只是想提高生产力，最后却变成了即使在所追求的事物不再让你快乐时、甚至在生活分崩离析时也无法退出。你投入120%精力的外部目标，归根结底，你知道的，
really great distractions for deeper dissatisfaction. It's a great way to never actually look at your life and contemplate what would truly make you happy and what is maybe under the surface that you need to unpack when you aren't able to hide behind constant goals, when you can't hide behind constant explanations or something bigger than yourself that you need to achieve. Here's another subtle but insidious trap that self-improvement content can sometimes trick us into, over intellectualizing and consuming without actually making changes. Consuming instead of applying, watching but never learning, thinking that we're doing something about a problem or an insecurity that we have
其实是对更深层不满的极好分散注意力的方式。这是永远不去审视自己的生活、不去思考到底是什么能真正让自己快乐、以及当无法躲在不断追求的目标背后、无法躲在不断的解释或需要实现的某种比自己更伟大的事物背后时，潜意识里到底有哪些需要解决的问题的绝佳方法。这里还有另一个微妙但阴险的陷阱，自我提升内容有时会诱使我们陷入其中：过度知识化和消费，却不付诸实际行动。只消费不应用，只观赏不学习，自以为正在解决某个问题或内心的不安全感，
when we're actually not really engaging on a deeper level. I think this is especially common when we excessively consume self-help content rather than apply it because we think that it's fixing something in our brain. When we bury ourselves in podcasts like this one or books or seminars, or online courses, and we're gathering vast amounts of information and psychological insights, but never actually implementing them into actionable steps. The thing about this is that it can feel productive, it can feel like you're doing something meaningful, but again, it is a form of false discipline or a form of procrastination or perhaps
而实际上并没有进行更深层次的参与。我认为这在过度消费自我帮助内容而不是去应用时尤为常见，因为我们以为这正在修复我们大脑中的某些东西。当我们沉浸在像这样的播客、书籍、研讨会或在线课程中，收集了大量的信息和心理学见解，但从未真正将它们落实为可操作的步骤时。关于这一点，它会让人觉得很有成效，会觉得你正在做一些有意义的事情，但同样，这是一种虚假的自律，或者是一种拖延的形式，也许
a substitute for real work. You know all the strategies. You know how to improve productivity. You know how to improve your relationships. but having knowledge and doing something about it are completely different things. Sometimes I feel like there's a certain kind of person who, and I used to be this, who consumes a lot of self-help content and becomes kind of like a knowledge hoarder rather than a knowledge supplier.
是真正工作的替代品。你知道所有的策略。你知道如何提高生产力。你知道如何改善人际关系。但是拥有知识和对此采取行动完全是两码事。有时我觉得有这样一种人——我过去就是这样——他们消费了大量的自助内容，变得有点像一个知识囤积者，而不是一个知识运用者。
And I think sometimes the reason that I at least did it and some other people may do it is because it feels like if we just know a little bit more, if we just know a little bit more, we have to know everything, then we can finally act. then we can finally make a decision about what the right thing is to do, but it just ends up being mental clutter. Like you just end up being more confused. That is why, you know, on my podcast, I always try to give you guys good tools that you can actually apply to your life
我想有时我之所以这样做（至少是我过去这样做），其他人也可能会这样做，是因为感觉只要我们再多了解一点，只要再多了解一点——我们必须了解一切——然后我们就能终于采取行动了。然后我们就能最终对什么才是正确的事情做出决定，但结果却只是一堆精神杂物。就像你最终只会变得更加困惑。这就是为什么，你知道的，在我的播客中，我总是试图给你们提供能够真正应用到生活中的好工具，
that are accessible and realistic so that what you're hearing isn't just information. It's things that you can implement. It's not just, you know, it's not just clutter. This is kind of a nice place to actually shift gears and talk, about what is a healthy approach to self-improvement. We kind of have already talked about it. I just want to give you a few more steps to identify when it is healthy versus unhealthy. A truly healthy approach to self-improvement thrives on, firstly, clarity around what you actually want to do and why you actually want to do it. Is this goal that you've set intrinsically
这些工具既平易近人又切实可行，因此你所听到的不仅仅是信息。它们是你能够付诸实践的东西。而不仅仅是，你知道的，不仅仅是杂乱无章的杂物。这其实是一个很好的契机，让我们转换话题，谈谈什么是健康的自我提升方法。我们其实已经讨论过了。我只想再给你几个步骤，来识别什么时候是健康的，什么时候是不健康的。一个真正健康的自我提升方法，首先繁荣于：对你真正想要做什么以及你为什么想做这件事有清晰的认知。你设定的这个目标是
or extrinsically motivated? Is there a genuine problem here or are you just searching for something wrong in your life as a proxy for something deeper that you don't actually want to address. A truly healthy approach is one that is quite honest, one that is quite honest about your intentions, your motivations, what you are actually capable of, and is honest about the outcome. This big thing that you may want, it probably won't completely change your life. It probably won't make you the most successful best version of you if you haven't done the deeper internal work in a practical way through therapy, through really knowing yourself, through experience, through testing yourself first. I think it's also important that you know what your
内在驱动的还是外在驱动的？这里真的存在问题，还是你只是在生活中寻找错误作为某种更深层次问题的替代品，而那个深层问题你其实并不想去解决。一个真正健康的自我提升方法是相当坦诚的，它对你的意图、你的动机、你实际能够做到什么保持坦诚，并且对结果保持坦诚。你可能想要的这个重大目标，大概不会彻底改变你的生活。如果你没有通过心理治疗、通过真正了解自己、通过经验、通过首先测试自己，以实际的方式完成更深层次的内在工作，它大概不会让你成为最成功、最好的自己。我认为同样重要的是，你要知道你的
enough point is. You know what you're really working towards before you start a project, before you start a new workout routine, before you start a goal, before you start, you know, a new career trajectory. For example, if you have a lofty goal of wanting to be fitter and healthier, you need some kind of end goal for that where you're going to allow yourself to sit back and just be happy. This really counteracts the idea that we have to constantly be getting better. You also need to have points where you can reflect and look back and see how far you've come. And sometimes having smaller goals or having enough point for the current phase of your goal, is really crucial so that you are constantly not just on a path that, or not just raising the bar on
“够了”的点在哪里。你知道在你开始一个项目、开始一个新的锻炼计划、设定一个目标、或者你知道的，开始一个新的职业轨迹之前，你真正努力的方向是什么。例如，如果你有一个想要变得更健康体魄的崇高目标，你需要为之设定某种最终目标，在这个目标里你将允许自己放松并感到快乐。这实际上抵消了我们必须不断变得更好的想法。你还需要有能够反思和回顾、看看自己已经走了多远的节点。有时，为当前阶段的目标设定更小的目标或“够了”的点，是极其关键的，这样你就不会一直处于一条道路上，或者不仅仅是在不断为自己
yourself, not just on a ladder that never ends. You're actually able to say, wow, I'm really proud of how far I've come. I'm really proud of where I am at right now. Maybe I don't need to get better. Maybe I don't need to improve from here. This is where I always imagined myself. This also requires, you know, setting realistic expectations based on your actual resources, not based on someone else's resources, not based on anyone else's commitment or energy levels or time. What are you actually capable of? Realistically. If you plan three runs and you run three times, that's a success.
提高标准，不仅仅是在一条永无止境的阶梯上。你实际上能够说，哇，我为自己走得这么远感到非常自豪。我为自己现在的处境感到非常自豪。也许我不需要变得更好。也许我不需要从这里开始提升。这就是我一直想象中的自己。这也需要，你知道的，根据你的实际资源来设定切合实际的期望，而不是根据别人的资源，不是根据任何其他人的承诺、能量水平或时间。现实地说，你实际上能做到什么？如果你计划跑三次步并且跑了三次，那就是成功。
Don't beat yourself up for not running five times like someone else. If running five times a week was never realistic. Please be careful with not setting parameters that can be achieved by people who don't have full-time jobs, don't have the same kind of financial stresses that you may have, have entire teams behind them, have personal assistance. Just because you can't meet that same level as them, doesn't mean you are failing. They wouldn't even be able to meet that same level
不要因为没有像别人那样跑五次而过分责备自己。如果一周跑五次从一开始就不切实际。请注意，不要设定那些只有全职工作、没有你可能承受的同样财务压力、背后有整个团队、有私人助理的人才能达到的参数。仅仅因为你无法达到与他们相同的水平，并不意味着你失败了。如果他们没有他们所拥有的资源，他们甚至无法达到那个水平
if they didn't have the resources that they had. When you are comparing yourself to someone online who seemingly has everything together and is the most efficient, productive person out there, take a second and think about, what you are not seeing, which is the amount of help that they receive, the amount of people that are on their teams, on their side, the luxury that is afforded to them by wealth, by significance, by having a platform. All of that does stack up. And just promise me that even if you have big
当你把自己和一个在网络上看起来拥有一切、效率最高、生产力最强的完美形象进行比较时，花一秒钟想想你没有看到的是什么：他们获得的帮助数、团队里有多少人站在他们这一边、由财富、声望以及拥有平台所带来的奢侈。所有这些确实都在叠加。请答应我，即使你有宏大
goals, which of course are important in which you are allowed and should have, just take a break every now and again and do something purely for the heck of it. Do something that serves no greater purpose that has no meaning that has nothing to do with success, nothing to do with productivity, nothing to do with your current goal, just do something just because you want to. Like, take a day off just because you want to. Go see a movie at 2pm just because you want to. Like, do something fun. Eat a mango in the shower.
的目标——这当然很重要，你也是被允许且应该拥有的——每隔一段时间也要休息一下，纯粹为了好玩而做点什么。做一些没有更大目的、没有意义、与成功无关、与生产力无关、与你当前目标无关的事情，仅仅因为你想做而去做。比如，仅仅因为你想而请一天假。下午两点去看电影，仅仅因为你想。比如，做点有趣的事。在淋浴时吃一个芒果。
Like, I don't know, just go to the dog park and just like lie and get cumbers from the dogs just because you want to. Like, I also want to stress again, life is not just about optimization. It's also about enjoyment. You will lead and you will find yourself constantly miserable if the only thing you ever enjoy or feel proud of doing is something that only comes from pushing yourself really, really hard. There are so many just like simple things that require no work to feel good about that
比如，我不知道，去狗公园，像那样躺着让狗狗们围着你，仅仅因为你想。比如，我还想再次强调，生活不仅仅是关于优化。它也是关于享受。如果你唯一享受或感到自豪的事情仅仅来自于把自己逼得非常非常紧，你将会一直过得很痛苦，并且会发现自己不断处于痛苦之中。有太多只需要付出零工作就能感觉良好的简单事情，
require no effort to enjoy. Make sure you have a good mixture of those things as well. Okay, we're going to take a short break, but when we return, I have a couple listener questions before we wrap up. So stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more
不需要付出努力就能去享受。确保你也有这些事情的良好组合。好了，我们要进行短暂的休息，但当我们回来时，在结束之前我还有几个听众提问。所以请继续收听。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析这个奇怪的现代世界中，关于心理韧性、健身以及建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康与健身专家进行对话，还有更多
to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominate the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
旨在看穿主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经坚信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你将会作为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人从另一端走出来。收听《2%》。即Heart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方的T-W-O-Persent。
There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist.
任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。规则一，永远不要惹乡下女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在这个新季的《闺蜜》中……天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。
I felt like I got hit. by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我觉得自己好像被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。所以她们决定自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼，才不。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝。在Iheart电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方。
Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down,
你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金姆有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析当时发生了什么，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed Correct. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
并试图理解我们是如何幸存下来的。包括最近一集请来了马克·拉蒙特·希尔，大谈80年代的可卡因。需要明确的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时准备谈论可卡因，但只是为了让你们都知道。我的意思是，马克，此时此刻，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里有一条主线。我们现在还有艾滋病摆在桌面上。
Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games.
谢谢你把那句话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史中对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你收听播客的任何地方回看它。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师卡尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。
And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing.
为了响应心理健康意识月，我将自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验以及与众多优秀嘉宾的对话带到了这里。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入这场追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。
And we're still chasing it, and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're free? Because that's two different intentions, bro.
而我们仍在追逐它，却不知道什么时候做得够了。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在这个世上做一个好人很重要？你是一个好人是因为你是自由的吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free, our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. Okay, welcome back to our discussion on self-improvement.
绝对是的。那是两种不同层面的信任。我希望你真正地成为一个好人。和我卡尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的IHeart Radio应用。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。好的，欢迎回到我们关于自我提升的讨论。
can't go too far, has it gone too far. We're going to talk through some more interesting questions that you guys sent me on the topic of self-improvement. Starting with this question, which I thought was just a really nice, lighthearted one to begin with, what are some actually good and worthwhile self-improvement resources that you personally use? I really like this question because, you know, obviously working in the space, like I do still engage in self-help content quite a bit and I still find it really useful to give me a
不能走得太远，它是不是走得太远了。我们将探讨你们发给我的关于自我提升主题的一些更有趣的问题。从这个问题开始，我觉得这是一个非常不错、轻松的话题来开场：你个人使用的是什么真正好且值得的自我提升资源？我真的很喜欢这个问题，因为你知道，显然在这个领域工作，我确实仍然经常接触自助内容，而且我仍然发现它对提供给我一个...
different perspective and interesting. A couple of books that I really love. The Alchemist, I think this book is self-helpy without being too self-helpy, and I love it. The Four Agreements, also kind of like another spiritual coded book that I find really interesting. The Untethered Soul is another one. I tend to prefer, like, more spiritual books for my self-help books, just because I spend so much time in the science with this podcast. I genuinely think I would read at least, or at least, look at 50 plus academic articles every single week. So I get enough from that when I engage in
不同的视角非常有用且有趣。我真的很喜欢几本书。《牧羊少年奇幻之旅》（The Alchemist），我认为这本书既有自助色彩又不会过于功利，我很喜欢它。还有《四项约定》（The Four Agreements），它也是那种带有精神密码的书，我觉得非常有趣。《臣服的实验》（The Untethered Soul）是另一本。我倾向于为我的自助书选择更多偏向精神层面的书，只是因为我花在这个播客上的科学时间太多了。我真心觉得我每周至少会阅读，或者至少浏览50多篇学术文章。所以我参与自助阅读时已经从那里面得到了足够多的东西。
self-help reading. I want something that's a bit more introspective and light, I guess not light, but a bit less scientific. I also really like personal memoirs. I think that personal memoirs are a really great place to start slash go-to, if you are kind of sick of, you know, reading the same old self-help books all the time. The book of joy is. another one that I really, really like. It's about happiness. It's about humanity. It's about gratitude. It's about what it means to live a good life, which I think is something we could all benefit from. I also really like the Dare app. It's like a meditation, anti-anxiety app that I find really useful and it's practical and it will get straight to the heart of your problem immediately,
我想要一些更具内省性和轻松感的东西，我想说不是轻松，而是稍微不那么科学化一些。我也非常喜欢个人回忆录。我认为，如果你有点厌倦了总是阅读那些老生常谈的自助书，个人回忆录是一个很好的起点或首选。另一本我非常非常喜欢的是《最后的馈赠》（The book of joy）。它关于幸福。它关于人性。它关于感恩。它关于过上好生活意味着什么，我认为我们所有人都能从中受益。我也非常喜欢Dare应用。它就像一个冥想、抗焦虑的应用，我发现它非常有用，而且很实用，能立刻切中你的问题核心，
especially if you're someone who's dealing with anxious thoughts or dealing with how to approach fear. also a podcast that I love, two podcasts that I love, I love Solgum by Victoria Hutchins, the Daily Victorian on Instagram. She has actually been on the podcast before. I just love how she intersects spirituality, philosophy, and psychology. I think that is so powerful. Do You Fucking Mind by Alexis Fernandez is also another podcast that I adore.
特别是如果你正在处理焦虑的想法或处理如何面对恐惧时。我还有两个非常喜欢的播客，我喜欢维多利亚·哈钦斯（Victoria Hutchins）的Solgum，即Instagram上的The Daily Victorian。她实际上以前上过这个播客。我只是喜欢她如何将灵性、哲学和心理学结合在一起。我认为这太强大了。亚历克西斯·费尔南德斯（Alexis Fernandez）的《Do You Fucking Mind》也是我崇拜的另一个播客。
She is also a personal friend of mine and she is a neuroscientist. I love getting content from people who know their shit. And I love getting content from people who are experts, but also have a lot of empathy rather than just like a one-track mind when approaching topics like this. I like people who are willing to see different sides of something and willing to open the door to a discussion or to different ways of approaching it rather than just being like, this is the best way to go about something and there is no other alternative. So those are kind of my favorite resources. This next question I really love, when is the right time to be disciplined versus when do I know that I need to take a break? I think you need to take a break when you don't
她也是我的个人朋友，她是一位神经科学家。我喜欢获取那些深谙此道的人的内容。我也喜欢获取那些既是专家又富有同理心的人的内容，而不是在处理此类话题时只有单一思维模式的人。我喜欢那些愿意看到事物不同面并愿意为讨论或不同处理方式打开大门的人，而不是那种说这就是做事最好方式而别无选择的人。所以这些算是我的最爱资源。接下来这个问题我真的很喜欢：什么时候是自律的正确时机，而我什么时候又知道自己需要休息了？我认为当你甚至...
even care about the outcome anymore. When you're thinking more about how other people will view you more than how this goal will change your view of yourself, when it's becoming suffocating, when it's overwhelming everything else, when there's nothing about it that you even slightly enjoy, when you just feel like you need a break is when you need a break. You know, discipline, it's incredible, it's a great skill, we need it to follow through. It can't be your whole life. Make sure you have some spontaneity and some fun. There was kind of a second part to this question, which is how to know when you've
不再在乎结果时，你就需要休息了。当你更多地考虑别人会如何看你，而不是这个目标将如何改变你对自己的看法时；当它变得令人窒息时；当它压倒了一切时；当你对它连一丝一毫的乐趣都感受不到时；当你觉得自己需要休息时，就是你需要休息的时候。你知道，自律是不可思议的，这是一项伟大的技能，我们需要它来坚持到底。但它不能成为你的全部生活。确保你有一些随性与乐趣。这个问题还有第二部分，那就是如何知道你已经...
consumed enough self-help content, so not just how to know when you've pushed yourself too far in terms of a goal, but how to know when you've overwhelmed yourself with more answers than you need. I think you know that you've consumed too much self-help content when you can't trust yourself anymore, when you always need someone else to give you the answer, to provide reassurance or an explanation, rather than just being prepared to learn through experience and to try things out and make mistakes. When you're intellectualizing and gathering information rather than doing things, you're missing out on the most crucial part of learning, which is
消耗了足够多的自助内容，所以不仅是如何知道什么时候在追求目标时把自己逼得太紧，而是如何知道什么时候你被超出你需要的答案搞得不堪重负。我认为当你不再信任自己时，你就知道自己消耗了太多的自助内容，当你总是需要别人给你答案、提供安慰或解释，而不是准备好通过经验去学习、尝试并犯错时。当你把事情知识化并收集信息而不是去行动时，你就错过了学习中最关键的部分，那就是...
of course, experience. There is only so much someone can tell you. There's only so much guidance someone can tell you before you have to go out there and try it yourself and feel it yourself. It's like someone can describe to you the most beautiful tasting cake, but you're not actually going to enjoy the taste of it until you try it yourself. Someone can, you know, tell you the most amazing way to get something out of life, like the most amazing mindset shift. You're not going to actually know what that feels like until you commit to trying it. Also, when you feel like you don't know what to think anymore and it's making you more confused rather than bringing you clarity, that's when I think you really need to take a step back and just like read something
当然，还有经验。别人能告诉你的是有限的。在你不得不亲自去尝试、去感受之前，别人能给你的指导也是有限的。就像别人可以向你描述世界上味道最美的蛋糕，但在你亲自尝试之前，你其实并不能真正享受到那种味道。别人可以，你知道的，告诉你从生活中获得某种东西的最棒方式，比如最棒的心态转变。但在你承诺去尝试之前，你其实并不知道那是什么感觉。此外，当你觉得自己不知道该想什么，而且这让你更加困惑而不是带给你清晰感时，我觉得这正是你需要退后一步，只是去读点...
different, watch something different, enjoy like your guilty pleasure TV show, watch some Love Island. Like there's no police that's going to come around and be like, you're brain rotting and you're consuming things that aren't intellectual. So like, we're taking away. that self-improvement badge from you. Like, you're not a fully optimized human, like, shame on you. No one's going to do that. It's actually good to let your brain be kind of gooey and kind of lizardy and kind of lizardy every now and again.
不同的东西，看点不同的东西，享受一下你的罪恶感快乐（guilty pleasure）电视节目，看一些《爱情岛》（Love Island）。就像没有警察会跑过来对你说，你的大脑在腐烂，你在消耗不具智识性的东西。所以，我们要剥夺你那个自我提升的徽章。就像，你不是一个完全优化的人，真为你感到羞耻。没有人会这么做。事实上，偶尔让你的大脑变得有点糊涂、有点原始（lizardy）也是一件好事。
This is a question that I really, really thought was important to bring up here because we didn't necessarily cover a lot of it in the episode. So hopefully I can give it some air time here. How does the self-improvement industry harm or influence our perceptions of chronic illness? I have been thinking a lot about this question since I first came across it in my Instagram DMs. I think the biggest issue is that the self-improvement industry is so focused on productivity and so focused on personal responsibility that it kind of implies that wellness is always within our control and it kind of implies that everyone should be capable of doing the same things when that is not the case.
这个问题我真的、真的觉得在这里提出来很重要，因为我们在那一集里不一定涵盖了太多的相关内容。所以希望我能在这里给它一些曝光时间。自我提升行业如何伤害或影响我们对慢性病的认知？自从我第一次在Instagram私信中看到这个问题以来，我一直在思考它。我认为最大的问题在于，自我提升行业太过于关注生产力，太过于关注个人责任，以至于它似乎暗示健康总是由我们自己控制的，并且似乎暗示每个人都应该有能力做同样的事情，而事实并非如此。
And just because your abilities are different doesn't mean you're worthless, just because you can't wake up at 5am and then, you know, go to bed at 12 and work as many hours as possible and do six workouts a day. Like just because you can't do that doesn't mean you're a failure, right? It just means that your body is different. And I think the wellness space in particular, particularly like the fitness space, self-improvement space, it's really focused on productivity and do. as much with your hours as possible. And often that muchness means a lot of effort and a lot of time and not a lot of rest. And if you are someone who struggles with exhaustion or has a kind of physical impairment or if you're someone who has a different brain to someone else, like, that's not always going to be possible for you. It doesn't mean that this person and people who
而且，仅仅因为你的能力不同并不意味着你毫无价值，仅仅因为你不能早上5点起床，然后，你知道的，12点睡觉，尽可能多地工作小时数，一天做六次锻炼。就像仅仅因为你做不到那些并不意味着你是个失败者，对吧？这只是意味着你的身体不同。我认为健康领域尤其是健身领域、自我提升领域，真的非常关注生产力和尽可能多地利用你的时间。通常那种“多”意味着付出大量的努力和大量的时间，却没有什么休息。如果你是一个与精疲力竭作斗争的人，或者有某种身体残障，或者你是一个大脑与别人不同的人，就像，这并不总是对你可能的。这并不意味着这个人以及那些...
are able to do that are better. I think it can also lead to a lot of shame. or guilt or a sense of failure that you are not able to work hard enough to heal yourself. You should be able to heal yourself through your mindset. If your mindset is strong enough, you can overcome anything, including a chronic condition. And it's like, that's literally ridiculous. Like, no. Like, no matter how powerful your mindset is, no matter how productive and efficient and powerful your mental state is.
能够做到这一点的人就更好。我认为这也会导致大量的羞耻感、内疚感，或者一种觉得自己无法通过努力工作来治愈自己的失败感。你应该能够通过你的心态来治愈自己。如果你的心态足够强大，你可以克服任何事情，包括慢性病。这就好比，这简直太荒谬了。就像，不。就像，无论你的心态多么强大，无论你的精神状态多么富有成效、高效和强大，...
So there are just things that aren't possible. And that doesn't mean that you are giving up. It just means that you understand your limits. And that in itself is actually a lot more powerful than just saying yes to everything. And being someone who can stretch themselves so thin that they become exhausted and actually take their health for granted. I think the space just sometimes really dismisses the realities of chronic illness. and it really oversimplifies and focuses more on mindset than it should. And it kind of sidelines the voices of those whose conditions don't fit into the industry
所以有些事情就是不可能的。这并不意味着你在放弃。这只是意味着你了解自己的极限。而这本身其实比对一切都说“好”要强大得多。作为一个会把自己榨干到筋疲力尽，实际上却把健康视为理所当然的人。我认为这个行业有时确实无视慢性病的现实，并且过度简单化，把过多的重点放在心态上，超出了它应有的限度。它在某种程度上边缘化了那些病情不符合该行业的群体...
as neat, you know, like before and after success stories. Or don't fit into this narrative that you can accomplish anything you put your mind to. Like, you could if you wanted to, but do you want to? And is that actually the best thing for your health? and should you force yourself to make yourself less well just to prove something to someone else, just to prove that you have worth because you can meet their standards, the standards that weren't set with you in mind? No. So I think it is actually a really big issue. And I think it's one that I really should do a whole episode on how self-improvement and the self-help space sidelines the voices
如整洁的（你知道的，比如前后对比的成功故事）的声音。或者不符合那种“只要你下定决心就能完成任何事情”的叙事。就像，如果你想的话你可以，但你真的想吗？这实际上对你的健康是最好的吗？你是否应该强迫自己让身体变得更糟，仅仅为了向别人证明些什么，仅仅为了证明你有价值，因为你能达到他们的标准——那些在设计时并没有把你的情况考虑进去的标准？不。所以我觉得这真的是一个很大的问题。而且我认为我真的应该做整整一集来探讨自我提升和自助空间是如何边缘化...
of people with chronic illnesses, not just mental health issues, but physical disabilities and so much more. because it is something that feels largely invisible. So thank you so much for that question. I'm going to do a whole episode on it, I think. So we'll talk about that more later down the line. I'm going to answer this final question. And I love this question. I love this question because it's a little bit different to what we've talked about.
患有慢性病的人的声音，不仅仅是心理健康问题，还包括身体残疾以及更多其他方面。因为这是一个在很大程度上感觉隐形的问题。非常感谢你提出这个问题。我想我会专门做一集来谈谈它。所以我们以后会进一步讨论这个问题。我要回答最后一个问题。我非常喜欢这个问题。我喜欢这个问题，因为它和我们讨论过的内容有点不同。
This person says, I don't get the hate with the self-improvement space. Is it really that bad to want better for myself? I don't think it's toxic to work hard. and I don't think that discipline is an evil word. I also agree with you, actually. I think that you are totally right. It's not bad to want better for yourself. It's actually amazing.
这个人说，我不明白为什么人们对自我提升空间有这么大敌意。想要让自己变得更好真的有那么糟吗？我不认为努力工作是有毒的，我也不认为自律是一个邪恶的词。其实我也同意你的看法。我认为你完全是对的。想要让自己变得更好并没有错。这其实太棒了。
And it's great that you've been able to identify something that, or a collection of things that you think will make your life better. But I do think the reason you believe this is because you have the right attitude. Everything that you are saying sounds like you meet all the kind of, all the checklists, all the categories for, someone who approaches self-improvement positively. You're doing it for intrinsic reasons. You're self-motivated.
而且你能找出一些东西，或者一系列你认为能让你的生活变得更好的东西，这真的很棒。但我确实认为你之所以有这种看法，是因为你有正确的心态。你所说的一切听起来都符合那种、所有清单上的、所有类别的要求，即一个积极对待自我提升的人。你这样做是出于内在的原因。你是自我驱动的。
You're doing it to align with your purpose. And it sounds like you're not falling into a toxic trap with discipline, which means that it's amazing for you. And it means that you are really focused on elevating yourself from an authentic position. I think I've laid out all the reasons that it becomes toxic. But just to reiterate them, it really becomes toxic when it's not for us, when it's for someone else, when we're not doing it for inherent enjoyment or for or to prove to ourselves something.
你这样做是为了与你的目标保持一致。听起来你并没有陷入自律的有毒陷阱，这意味着这对你来说太棒了。这意味着你真的专注于从一个真实的立场来提升自己。我想我已经列出了它变得有毒的所有原因。但重申一下，当它不是为了我们自己，而是为了别人；当我们不是为了天生的乐趣或为了向自己证明某些事情而去做时，它真的就会变得有毒。
And when it's dominating our entire lives so that there is space for nothing else. Nothing is ever entirely one thing or another. The same can be said about self-improvement. There are such beautiful parts of it and I continue to have goals that I want to strive towards. I continue to have things about my life that I do think could be better. But I also don't let that take away from the appreciation that I have for the things in my life. that are already great. And I think that is the healthy space to be in and it sounds like you're in that healthy space as well. So congratulations. Thank you so much if you have made it this far. I want to
当它主宰了我们的整个生活，以至于容不下其他任何东西时。没有任何东西是完全非黑即白的。自我提升也是如此。其中有非常美好的部分，我也有想要努力实现的目标。我仍然觉得生活中有一些地方可以变得更好。但我也不会让这一点夺走我对生活中已经很棒的事物的感激之情。我认为这是健康的相处空间，听起来你也处于那种健康的相处空间中。所以恭喜你。如果你已经坚持到了这一步，非常感谢。我想...
hear your thoughts about self-improvement in the comments below. If you agreed, if you didn't agree with something that I said, even better, what are your thoughts? How do you know when it's gone too far in your life? But also, I want you to share a piece of content, a self-improvement, project, book, podcast series, seminar, whatever it is that you think is actually a genuinely positive beacon of light in this space and that you think people should be engaging in. What are the positive examples of self-improvement that you consume or that you see that you think others could benefit from knowing from as well? So thank you again for listening. Make sure that you are following along wherever you are listening to this podcast on Apple, on Spotify, on the IHeart Radio app. I don't know
在下方的评论区听听你对自我提升的看法。如果你同意，或者不同意我所说的话，那就更好了，你有什么看法？你怎么知道它在你的生活中已经走得太远了？同时，我也希望你分享一些内容，一个自我提升项目、书籍、播客系列、研讨会，无论是什么，你认为它是这个领域中真正积极的光芒，并且你认为人们应该参与其中。你消费或看到的、你认为其他人也能从中受益的自我提升的积极例子有哪些？所以再次感谢你的收听。确保无论你在哪里收听这个播客，都要关注它，在Apple上，在Spotify上，在IHeart Radio应用上。我不知道...
where you're listening from, but make sure you hit that for. follow slash subscribe button. Make sure that you leave a five-star review as well if you feel called to do so and share this episode with a family member, with a friend, with a colleague, with your followers. If you think that this is a discussion that needs to go further than just you and I, I think that it's something we need to talk about more and I hope others agree with me. So I'd love for you to be able to share it and bring more people's attention to this. As always, as we wrap up our episode, I want to remind you all to stay safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. And as always, we will talk very, very soon. Thanks for joining me.
你是在哪里收听的，但请确保点击那个关注/订阅按钮。如果你觉得有必要的话，请留下五星好评，并将这一集分享给家人、朋友、同事、你的粉丝。如果你认为这是一场不仅需要你我参与、还需要进一步深入的讨论，我认为这是我们需要更多谈论的事情，我希望其他人也同意我的看法。所以我很希望你能分享它，并引起更多人对这一点的关注。一如既往，在我们结束这一集之际，我想提醒大家注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔以待。一如既往，我们很快就会再聊。感谢你的加入。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。欢迎收听我的播客《2%》。我在这里剖析我们在奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。那是“TWO percent”。在《Look Back at it》播客节目中。对1979年来说，那对我是个重大时刻。84年对我也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for Black.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、喜剧演员同仁以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。1984年是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为没有比这更重要的一年了。
at people. Listen to look back at it on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with.
针对黑人群体。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，各位好吗？你们正在收听由你们喜爱的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在其他地方绝对不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套铠甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the IHare radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through.
而且仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就非得这么做。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。埃伦女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大群网络侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。还有两个男人经历过。
the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues,
同样的事情。格雷格，一个女同性恋者，迈克尔·兰吉尼。我震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，
Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一个iHeart播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。